هذا المساء هو أول لقاء لنا يوم 28 مايو
لقد فعلنا ذلك من أجل
أنا هنا وأنا هنا وأنت هنا أيضًا
أقسم بالله حتى النهاية
سأقاتل، هذا صحيح، لكن سأخسره يا أردوغان
في هذه الانتخابات، وهي استفتاء
ولم يحصل على تصويت بالثقة
18 من أصل 31 نائباً في إسطنبول
واحد منهم ليس من حزبنا يستقيل غدا
ما هو الخط الذي يجري كمال
يجب على الرجل أن يستقيل من هذا اليوم
كنا سنقول اليوم هو اليوم وإلى الشارع
وخرج التصويت ليقول إن رجب طيب أردوغان خسر
نحن الوحيدون الخاسرون هنا
نحن نبكي
يمكننا أن نقول ذلك بأمان
مرشحنا للرئاسة د.
Kılıçdaroğlu بلدنا الليلة
سيتم إعلانه رئيسا
[موسيقى]
عمل جيد لأمتنا
نحن نبذل قصارى جهدنا للحصول على النتائج.
سنفعل هذا أو ذاك الآن
نحن لا نقول أبدا أننا سوف ندعم
لن نقول
[موسيقى]